the jurgen experience i guess we should
start off
with um what made you write this book
what was the
motivation for doing this yeah so i'm a
i'm a philosopher by training
and philosophers have always been kind
of really eager to
to invest to test ideas and try to weed
out
weed out the bad ones that's that's kind
of what we philosophers do
and a lot of times that doesn't make us
particularly popular
but i argue in the book that the
philosophical method of
belief testing called say the socratic
method right famous
process pioneered by a greek philosopher
thousands of years ago
basically if you test ideas with
questions and then toss out the ones
that don't withstand scrutiny
that's a way to strengthen your mind's
resistance to bad ideas
um so so here's the here's the
kind of the skinny on this and i think
that the people who get this concept
are going to be the thought leaders of
the next few decades
we know our bodies have immune systems
and their job
is to hunt down parasites and pathogens
and eliminate them and some of those
antibodies actually consume
pathogens in our body now the new
information which is just now coming
together
in philosophy and in the sciences is
that our minds have immune systems just
like our bodies do
only a mental immune system's job is to
hunt down
and remove mind parasites
or bad ideas
i've never seen you speechless before no
i'm not speechless so i just didn't know
if you were done with your sentence
i understand that the mind parasites can
ruin your mind and that these uh the
concept of mental immunity of some some
sort of
mental immune system but like what what
kind of mental immune system are you
talking about are you talking about
meditation are you talking about
uh a specific way of addressing issues
and problems
and how do you factor in things like
emotions yeah
so let me start simple with a little
thought experiment maybe okay
play along with me here so it's kind of
a story so imagine
we are sitting around a bonfire
tossing back a few beers okay and i say
hey joe
reach into the fire there grab me one of
those hot coals and hand it to me
what do you say i say i'm not really
interested in doing that andy
okay good and and what what what what
went on in your head
that made you say that uh it seems like
i'd get injured doing that yeah
yeah so you ran a little simulation in
your mind
and you concluded that that would be
harmful yes right
that was your mind's immune system at
work that simulation run so basically i
was serving up an idea
a suggestion hey joe do this for me
you ran a little simulation in your mind
you identified that idea as a bad one
you sp your mind's immune system was
strong enough and well functioning
enough to spot this bad idea
and you came out [ __ ] you andy reach
into the fire again i didn't
kill that hard andy that's true
i'm just trying to i'm just trying to
speak you're trying to speak your
language is that my language
okay i might say that if we're in front
of the fire honestly
i mean like hey man [ __ ] you um but
yeah so i see what you're saying so but
how do you but it seems a little bit
more complicated when you're addressing
ideas
because one of the problems with these
ideas is uh some of them are very
attractive
yes you know like i was watching the
dumbest video yesterday where people
were thinking that when they're getting
the
covet vaccine that they're getting
microchipped and they're approving it
with magnets
they were sticking magnets on themselves
and the magnets were clinging to the
area where they got the covet shot
and they were from this they were
concluding that you're getting
microchipped
and that somehow none of this magnet was
being held in place
so i take it you would call you would
think of that as a mind parasite
i i don't know what that is i mean i
think it's a it's
it's either a hoax or how about a
conspiracy theory can we go there
yeah sure so let me tell you a second
story so okay our first example there
was a
uh of your mental immune system
functioning properly to spot
a bad idea and say nope you're not
welcome here right right
now let's take an example of a mental
immune system misfiring
okay all right so um this is a story
about fred the flat earther
so fred dies he goes to heaven saint
peter meets him at the pearly gates
he says come on in fred you're our lucky
customer number 100
you get a chance to chat with god so
fred marches right in to god's inner
sanctum
and says so god i've been a conspiracy
theorist my whole life a flat earther my
whole life i gotta know
is the world's flat or is it round
god shakes his head does a face palm and
says
i'm sorry to say fred but the world is
very round
fred's face register shock and then
recognition
and he said this conspiracy theory goes
higher than i thought
that's probably exactly what they would
do too well and especially flat earthers
well
and what does this joke tell us about
the conspiracy mentality
right and you say that's exactly what it
would do because i think you understand
something about conspiracy thinking
which is that a conspiracy theory
infected mind
becomes so good at generating antibodies
to fight back against even good
information
that it'll that those antibodies will
attack the good information so here's
god telling you the truth right yeah
your mind
and friends and mental antibodies just
rush in
and and dismiss it as part of a
even deeper conspiracy that that's so
so questions doubts suspicions those are
the mind the mind's
antibodies all right and
they can go nuts they can they can go on
hyperactive
um in the same way that the body's
immune system can go haywire
and attack your body itself your mind's
immune system can go haywire
and your questions and your doubts and
your suspicions can attack your mind
um i think one of the problems with uh
conspiracy theories and people that
believe uh
foolish things is that they don't really
seek the truth they seek something that
confirms
what they want to be true yes and they
ignore
things to the contrary and there's even
uh
word psychologists have a word for this
called confirmation bias
right i'm sure you've heard of it um
yeah it feels good to be validated
and so yeah a lot of times we come to a
belief that makes us comfortable that
feels good to us
and then we just seek out information
that confirms it but we actually dismiss
or ignore
or diminish anything that might conflict
with it
but the problem is that'll send you down
a rabbit hole
oh yeah catch new episodes of the joe
rogan experience for free
only on spotify watch back catalog jre
videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly
switch between video and audio
experience on spotify you can listen to
the jre
in the background while using other apps
and can download episodes to save on
data cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre
episodes you just need to search for the
jre
on your spotify app go to spotify now
to get this full episode of the joe
rogan experience